Have you ever felt like the world of
math seems confusing or irrelevant? It can
certainly feel that way sometimes,
especially if it is explained without any
sort of real world context. But math is
not simply a set of rules. It's an
intricate and fascinating language that
we've developed to understand and describe
the world around us. >> In this course we
will approach college algebra using three
real world scenarios. First, we'll have a
new startup company, with a very creative
product, figure out how to handle it's
finances. >> Next, we'll look at how
architects use mathematics to design
concert halls. >> At the end of the
course, we'll talk about how to model the
population change of endangered species
and invasive species. >> These scenarios
will help you develop a deep understanding
of algebra and teach you how to solve
problems more effectively. >> So join us
to learn how intuitive, relevant, and
compelling algebra can be.